But now let me give you some scripture
to encourage you.
You are not to freak out.
You're not to get paranoid.
You are not to overthink things because
that's how Satan will win, cause you
paranoia where you don't trust in God
and that's it. So let me give you some
words of encouragement. Put things in
perspective.
Put thing Put things in perspective,
right?
And I'm going to begin.
Just want to encourage you. But go watch
the film Snake Eyes and Contagion.
Tell me if life doesn't imitate art.
All right. Now watch.
You are not called to paranoia. Romans
8:15 but we'll read 15 to 17.
Right? You are not called to freak out.
Okay. You're called
to peace and and
trust.
Knowing God Almighty is sovereign, your
lives are in his hands.
So don't freak out because if you freak
out that means you don't trust Jesus.
You fear man more than the Lord and
that's sin. But you know that's sin.
Okay. So let me just give you some
scripture to remind you don't get
paranoid.
Don't freak out. Let me see what else to
give you.
Yeah, I'm sure he'll give me more of the
Holy Spirit. Whatever you want me to
give them, Lord.
Okay.
Yeah, here.
All right. Let's start with these. Okay?
Ready?
Word of encouragement.
You're ready?
Isaiah 8:12-14.
You are not to say it is a conspiracy
in regard to all that this people call a
conspiracy. Isn't it amazing?
The Bible has the answer for everything.
It even tells you don't freak out, don't
panic
over things that they're calling
conspiracies
and which causes them to panic.
You want me there?
You see that, Rumble, Maga?
Do you see that right there?
Isn't it amazing? The Bible has the
answers for everything.
700 years before our Lord was born, God
told Isaiah to tell his people don't
freak out, don't panic
over what they call a conspiracy.
See that?
And you are not to fear what they fear
and you shall not tremble.
Don't freak out
over these eye ops where you're a
paranoid person and cannot live at
peace.
So then who do you fear?
Who do you trust?
Really, Kenny Mason? I mentioned this
months ago.
It is Yahweh of hosts whom you should
regard as holy. Fear him, trust in him.
He's almighty, not
creatures.
And he shall be your fear and he shall
be your cause of trembling.
And then he shall become a sanctuary
meaning you know how you have these
sanctuaries where you run to for safety
and protection? He's your safe haven.
He is your sanctuary.
Mr. Anna, good seeing you, brother.
But to both the houses of Israel, a
stone to strike and a rock to stumble
over and a snare and a trap for the
inhabitants of Jerusalem meaning anyone
who hates God, opposes God,
God will be a snare to them. God will be
a source of stumbling to them. God will
crush them, those who don't trust in
him.
Here.
Peter then quotes
quotes Isaiah 8.
Peter quotes Isaiah 8
verses 12-13. But even if you should
suffer for the sake of righteousness you
are blessed, do not fear their fear, do
not be troubled. But sanctify Christ as
Lord in your hearts. Let me explain what
he means.
Be determined
and resolve it in your mind
to have no doubt about the fact Jesus
lives and he reigns as Lord.
Let me explain what he's saying here.
Exactly, Chan. I'll get there in a
minute. Let me explain what he's saying
here.
If you know and have no doubt Christ is
risen, he's alive
and you know this for a fact and you
know he's almighty over creation,
then
you have nothing to fear. That's what
he's saying.
Set apart the fact.
Know this in your hearts and minds.
Do not be shaken from this conviction.
Jesus reigns as Lord.
Exactly, Paula.
And because he's Lord,
there is nothing that can separate you
from him and destroy you from him.
Yes, you may go through trials, you may
even be homeless, you may even be
imprisoned and killed, but he'll give
you the power to endure if you trust
him.
And so when they ask you, "Why is it you
put your hope and trust in this
crucified man?"
Paul says Peter says, I'm sorry. Then be
ready to make a defense. Explain why.
He's not dead, he's alive. They're going
to ask you to give an account for the
hope that is in you. "Why do you have
this hope
in this man who was recently killed?"
Cuz he's not dead, he's alive.
With gentleness and fear, but that's to
those who are honestly asking cuz the
same Peter says those who pervert the
truth, they're dogs and pigs. Second
Peter 2.
All right. Again, let me give you some
scriptures. We're going to get in topic,
I promise. That's why I said about I
have about 3 hours. Lord, increase our
numbers for your glory not for my
praise.
Okay, you you're following me, everyone?
Screen is large enough you can see the
verses. All right, good.
This one.
For God has not given us a spirit of
timidity. So then why are you afraid?
Why are you paranoid? Why are you
freaking out?
Why are you afraid?
Why are you paranoid? Why are you
freaking out?
The spirit in you
energizes you, strengthens you,
and reassures you Jesus is Lord and you
are in his hands.
So why are you freaking out?
But a power, he gave you power and
self-control. Why do you think I asked
you to pray for me the Lord give me
self-discipline?
Therefore, do not be ashamed of either
the witness of our Lord or me as
prisoner. When Paul is writing this just
to give you a reminder,
Paul is in prison, Maga.
Paul is in prison.
He's about to be beheaded.
Okay?
He is practicing what he's preaching.
I'm in prison and I'm not freaking out,
I'm not paranoid.
But join with me in suffering for the
gospel according to the power of God.
Who has saved us and called us with a
holy calling meaning he called you to
holiness, living separate. By the way,
let me explain the word kadosh and
hagios.
In the Hebrew and Greek, kadosh, holy,
hagios, holy, means to be separated, to
be set apart, right?
When we say you need to be holy, let me
break that down for many people don't
know it. Go look at any lexicon,
right? Go look at any lexicon.
It means to separate, to set apart.
Okay.
What does holiness mean?
To be separate from the world, separate
from the way the world does things,
separate from the way
Satan
inspires the world to behave and act.
Separate from this corrupt world under
the influence of Satan.
Separate yourself from the way they
think, the way they behave, the way they
act.
And think like God, behave like God, act
like God. That's what the word holiness
means.
Yep, do not be afraid. Do not be afraid.
Do not be afraid.
Do you know that's what it means? I'm
not lying. Go look at the lexicon.
Kadosh, the word he holy, and hagios
means separate.
Be separate, separated, set apart.
Right?
So when you're
set
to be holy means you are no longer
agreeing with the world, behaving like
the world, acting like the world cuz the
world's under the influence of Satan
and it's in opposition to God.
And it's going to be destroyed cuz this
planet will be transformed, there'll be
no more evil permeating it.
So don't think like the world, don't act
like the world, don't behave like the
world. Think like God, behave like God,
act like God. So, if the world says
abortion is okay, you condemn that,
that's murder.
The world says same-sex relation okay,
you condemn that as an abomination.
The world says sex before marriage is
okay, that's evil. And may God have
mercy on us. I know it's a struggle for
all of us. We need to fight it.
You understand what it means?